[music playing]
HAZEN AUDEL: The Mani have
an unrivaled knowledge
of the local plants and trees,
relying on them for almost
everything they need.
[non-english speech]
Huh?
That one right there.
[non-english speech]
Oh.
It's basically like a palm tree.
And it is spiky and
thorny everywhere on it.
[non-english speech] Up there?
[non-english speech]
You just climb this to
get all the way up there.
Look at that.
The Mani are expert climbers.
Training begins at a young age.
By adulthood, they're
able to scale the tallest
trees in the forest.
Now, that man can climb a tree.
It makes perfect sense
because in a forest like this,
it's a whole 'nother
world out there.
And to the Mani, half their
meat market and grocery store
is up in those branches.
He's doing this
all methodically.
All this comes with
a lot of practice.
OK, yeah, this is the stuff.
It's like this really felty
material, really fibrousy.
It's the stuff that
grows between the really
spiky outer bark in the
inner cambium up there.
[music playing]
Nice.
[laughs]
This plant fiber makes
excellent tinder,
but we've collected it
for a different purpose.
[non-english speech]
Take one of these?
OK.
These are target darts.
[non-english speech]
No poison on the end.
Oh, OK.
Take this.
So this little wadding,
shove that right in there.
And then that totally
completes the air seal.
Huh?
Making the tube airtight
allows us to fire the darts
using the power of our lungs.
[inaudible] has been hunting
with blow guns since he was 15.
These powerful precision weapons
rely on an expert combination
of steady aim and timing.
Bullseye.
That is just straight
and powerful.
Blow guns are handmade in the
village using a special bamboo
called [inaudible].
Two tubes are carefully heated
and massaged over hot coals,
and are made to be as
straight as possible.
They are then glued together
using a sticky tree resin.
This extra length provides
deadly force and accuracy.
Launching?
Darts at several
hundred miles per hour.
Look at that.
Just to see how
powerful, this dart went
all the way through the target.
Now, it's my turn.
It's a good thing these things
are light, because there's
a lot of leverage on the end.
But then, your hands
don't get in the way
of siting the blowgun.
I got this.
[groans]
Yeah, I didn't
make it that time.
[inaudible]
It'll take some practice.
It went way into the jungle.
During a hunt, you rarely
get a second chance.
I need to demonstrate this
is a skill I can master.
OK, so how do you
hold your hands?
Just put that on the bottom.
Oh, wow, OK.
So you lock your two
index fingers up on top.
There we go!
Yeah, bullseye, bullseye.
Nice, nice, getting
more practice.
They fire so fast and accurate,
they really jam in there.
MANI PERSON:
[non-english speech]
Huh?
MANI PERSON:
[non-english speech]
Yeah, [non-english speech].
Good deal, good deal.
yeah, yeah, nice.
Starting to get
the hang of this.